largas filas en la frontera entre kosovo
y serbia este domingo la minoría serbia
del norte de kosovo realizó bloqueos y
se escucharon disparos contra la policía
desde este 1 de agosto kosovo pretendía
dar dos meses para que los serbios
adoptasen documentos administrativos
kosovares reglas similares a las pides
serbia a sus vecinos tras diálogos con
eeuu y la unión europea kosovo retrasó
la medida hasta el 1 de septiembre
aunque acusó al gobierno serbio
múltiples actos violentos fueron
perpetrados este domingo instigados y
planeados por las autoridades de
belgrado en el norte de kosovo hay una
minoría de unos 50.000 serbios no
reconocen a las instituciones kosovares
desde belgrado consideran que es un paso
más para expulsarlos de kosovo donde la
mayoría de la población es albanesa y
musulmana
a su modo lo que puedo decir es que
buscaremos la paz pero también digo no
habrá rendición y serbia ganará si se
atreven a perseguir a los serbios
tratarlos y a matarlos serbia ganar a
prevenir su víctima
kosovo declaró su independencia de
serbia en 2008 la reconoce en más de 100
países y eeuu es uno de sus principales
aliados rusia a la rechaza de hecho la
polarización en torno a ucrania se
siente en las calles de los dos países
esto es prístina la capital kosovar y
esto del grado capital serbia
un conflicto que viene de lejos entre
1998 y 1999 hubo un alzamiento albaneses
en kosovo
por aquel entonces parte de serbia se
desató una sangrienta represión del
gobierno serbio hasta que la otan
bombardeó el territorio obligando a los
serbios a salir todavía hoy hay una
misión de paz de 28 países con 3800
soldados